The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last
time you learned
about the ideal solution limits
with Henry's law and Raoult's
law.
And I just want to start
with one reminder of what
this is all about.
So let's say that you have a
mixture of CS2 and acetone.
So this is a review of
what you saw last time.
Acetone like this, CH3, CH3.
And if you take the CS2 as
the solvent and the acetone
as a solute, then when you plot
as a function of the amount
of CS2 here as a
solvent, then you
have the limit where the mole
fraction of CS2 goes to one,
meaning that CS is the solvent.
You expect Raoult to work
if it's an ideal solution.
So that the vapor
pressure of CS2
is related to the mole
fraction of CS2 times the vapor
pressure of CS2 if it was pure.
So you're sitting
here somewhere.
This is the vapor
pressure of CS2 pure
and CS2 goes from zero to one.
And you expect Raoult to work.
So let's do Raoult.
Like this.
So in this area, if I were
to plot the real curve,
I would expect it to start
out just like Raoult.
And then there's going
to be some deviation.
Then if I take the other limit,
where the mole fraction of CS2
goes to zero.
So now the CS2 is the solute.
And the acetone is
the solvent. what
happens for this
particular mixture is
that Henry's law
is no longer valid.
Raoult's law is not valid here.
Instead, you have to
look at Henry's law.
And Henry's law tells you
that for the solute now,
not the solvent,
so the CS2 here is
the solute, very
small amount of it.
Very small mole fraction.
That the vapor
pressure of the solute
is related to the mole
fraction in the solution.
But instead of having the vapor
pressure of the pure solute,
you have another number.
Another constant.
Which we call K. Which is
a Henry's law constant.
And this constant depends on
what else in the solution.
It depends on the fact that
you have acetone in there.
You would have a
different constant
if the acetone were replaced
with chloroform, let's say.
So this constant here
cares what the solvent is.
And it cares what the
temperature is, also.
There's a lot of stuff that's
built into this constant here.
It's a phinemelogical constant.
And in the case of the
mixture of CS2 and acetone,
the deviation from
Raoult's law is positive.
Meaning that the
Henry's law constant
is greater than the vapor
pressure of the pure CS2.
So that means that
the molecules of CS2
would rather go
in the gas phase.
If there's acetone around.
That means they don't
like to mix so much.
They're not happy
with each other.
So the CS2 molecules
would rather
escape what would normally be
a Raoult's law type of solution
to go in the gas phase away
from being close to the acetone.
And as a result you get
this positive deviation.
You get a higher pressure than
you expect from Raoult's law.
So that the slope here
This slope here is K CS2.
And that slope
here is p star CS2.
This is a positive deviation.
And you saw an example where
you if you mix chloroform
and acetone, you get
a negative deviation.
Chloroform and acetone
are happy together
because of the hydrogen
bonding between the oxygen here
and the hydrogen in chloroform.
And you get a
negative deviation.
So let's start by doing
an example with numbers.
Of how this might come about.
Any questions on this first?
I always got confused with
Henry's law and Raoult's law.
And I always got
confused as to when
I was supposed to
use Henry's law
and when I was supposed
to use Raoult's law.
Very confusing to me, initially.
The thing to remember
is that if you're
talking about something which
in a very small amount, just
the solute, like, well I'm going
to give you an example which
is a bad example,
like sugar and water.
Where sugar is
clearly the solute,
but sugar is not volatile
clearly this is a bad example.
But something which in a very
small concentration, then
Henry's law is going to apply.
Raoult's law is only going
to apply for the solvent.
When you have a lot
of stuff around.
On this side here
is Raoult's law.
is Henry's law.
Henry's law, the deviation's
from Raoult's law,
are going to happen where
the molecules in the solution
mostly see molecules that
are not like themselves.
If they mostly see
molecules like themselves,
since it's an ideal
solution, then they
don't know that there's
other stuff around.
In this case here, the CS2
molecules don't really know.
Most of them don't know that
there's any acetone around.
They couldn't care less.
So it obeys an ideal solution.
Here, they don't see
any other CS2 molecules.
They mostly see acetone.
And so Raoult's law is
going to fall apart.
Because Raoult's
law assumed that you
have a single component.
Or mostly one component.
OK.
Let's do an example.
So in this case
here, we're going
to work the example out here.
So let's take two
components, A and B. Where
B is, and let's look
at something which
is a dilute solution
and non-ideal.
So there's going to be some
deviation from Raoult's law.
And what we're told
is at 50 degrees
Celsius, that the vapor pressure
of pure A is equal to 0.67 bar.
And the vapor pressure of
pure B is equal to 1.2 bar.
So B is clearly
the more volatile.
And we're also told,
then, that at 50 degrees
C we have a molar fraction of
A in the liquid phase is 0.9.
And the molar fraction of B
in the liquid phase is 0.1.
And the total pressure above
the solution is 0.7 bar.
And eventually what we're
going to try to find out is,
we're going to change
these concentrations.
Are we going to
try to figure out
how the total pressure
above the solution changes.
That's maybe the
goal of the problem.
When you change this
to, eventually we'll
change it to 0.95
and 0.05, and we'll
want to know how does that
change the total pressure.
So immediately we see
that this is a solvent.
This is a solute.
This is volatile.
So, we're close to
where this is zero.
So if we're going to apply any,
sort of, Raoult or Henry's law
problem to this,
this is probably
going to be Henry's law for
B and Raoult's law for A.
We're going to be close
to this area here for B.
to this area for A.
OK.
So ah the first
question is, what's
the composition
in the gas phase.
What is y sub B. And it looks
like this particular set
of notes doesn't have
the calculations.
I'm going to go to my other set
of notes here that has them.
So, because I'm going
to make a mistake if I
go through it
without my notes, I'm
going to leave it up
to you to do part a.
That's a good way
out of making a mess.
I'm just going to
tell you the answer.
Because the actual,
the interesting part,
is part b of the problem.
Part a is the easy part.
So this is something that
you can do on your own.
So yB is equal to 0.139.
Is going to be answer to
part b, given these two molar
fractions and the
total pressure.
So now, what we're
going to do is,
we're going to change
the molar fractions
and we're going to
find out how that
changes the total pressure.
So, second part is we're
still at 50 degrees Celsius.
And we're going to change the
molar fraction of A to 0.95.
And the molar
fraction of B to 0.05.
And we're going to ask,
what is p total now.
So we write what we know.
Which is that we
expect p total to be
the sum of the partial pressures
of A and B. A is the solvent,
B is the solute.
It's a dilute
non-ideal solution. pA
is going to be proportional
to Raoult's law,
because it's a solvent.
It's in large quantities.
So it's going to be xA pA star.
And xB is going, and
pB is going to be
proportional to the
mole fraction again.
But because it's a solute, it's
seen most the other molecules
of A around, it's
not necessarily
going to be obeying
Raoult's law.
It's going to obey Henry's law.
It's going to be close
to the zero point.
There's going to be a deviation
because of the interactions
between A and B.
Which dominate now.
So instead of pA
star, we have KB here,
where this is the
Henry's law constant.
Which depends on the
fact that A is around.
We get a different constant
if we have a different solvent
around.
So we know this.
We know this because that was
given to us at the beginning.
But we don't know this here.
We don't know what the
Henry's law constant here is.
But we can get it.
We can get it from part a here.
Because we have all the
information we need there.
So from part a, we
already have a mixture
where we're given
the total pressure.
So from part a,
KB is pB over xB.
And we calculated
what yB is over there.
On part a.
So we know what the
partial pressure of B is.
It's the molar fraction
of B in the gas
phase times the total pressure.
That's Dalton's law.
Then we divide by xB.
And then we plug in
the number 0.139 times
the total pressure
up there is 0.7.
Divided by 0.1.
And we get that
this is 0.973 bar.
So now we can plug this
in to our equation here.
We know xA, we know xB, we know
Raoult's law, the 0.67 pA star.
We know KB here.
We plug in all the
numbers, and we
get that the total
pressure is now 0.685 bar.
This is a pretty typical
example of a problem that
combines Raoult's law, Henry's
law and Dalton's law together.
And keeping track of these laws
takes a little bit of thinking.
And it's very, very common
on problem sets or exams
to mix these up.
So it's good to go
through examples like this
and really keep track of
where each law applies.
Dalton's law applies
in the gas phase.
It's partial pressure
Henry's law is the pressure.
If you know what's happening in
the liquid phase, for a solute.
Raoult's law is the partial
pressure in the gas phase,
if you know what's happening
in the liquid phase.
So Raoult and Henry tell you
something about the pressure
if you know the liquid.
Dalton only deals with what's
happening in the gas phase.
OK, any questions
on the problem?
Alright.
So we did this problem
here, and now let's
draw the phase diagram for our
solute here, or for B, rather.
Zero to one.
And let's take a vote here.
So if Raoult's law worked for
B, for the mixture of A and B,
then we would have pB star here.
And everything would be great.
But Raoult's law doesn't work.
Close to molar fraction of zero.
Instead, Henry's law.
There's a deviation,
due to the interactions
between the molecules
A and B here.
So we have two choices
for the deviation.
We can have a
positive deviation,
or we could have a
negative deviation.
Positive deviation,
if the molecules of B
would rather be
in the gas phase,
than be in the mixture
in the liquid phase.
Meaning they don't
like molecules of A.
They don't like to be
mixed with molecules
of A. The energy of
interaction is not favorable.
The enthalpy is not
favorable, for mixing
A and B. In this case
here, the enthalpy
is favorable for mixing A and B.
So in this problem here,
which do you think it is?
The blue one or the green one.
Let's raise hands here.
How many people think
it's the blue one here.
Anybody else?
The right answer,
we have four people.
How many people think
it's the green one?
Four.
Five.
Six.
You didn't vote twice, did you?
Vote early, vote often, right?
Mayor Daley, the old
Mayor Daley in Chicago.
And if you know somebody
who's dead, vote for them.
OK, so this is the, I've
got about five people here.
And a bunch of
people didn't vote.
So it's a tie.
It's basically a tie here.
I think you should
think about this.
Maybe talk to each
other a little bit.
See if you can figure
out, given all the numbers
that are in this
problem here, you
know what, the pure
pressure on the solvent is.
We change concentrations here.
Got Henry's law constant out.
And Henry's law
constant is going
to tell you whether or not
that enthalpy of interaction
is favorable or not favorable.
It's going to be a
positive deviation
or a negative deviation.
OK, shall we vote again.
How many people say
it's the blue one?
it's the green one.
Thank you.
Alright.
Good.
We have K sub B is
less than p star,
therefore it's a
negative deviation.
The pressure is less
than you'd expect.
The molecules like each
other better than you expect.
There is a favorable enthalpy
of interaction between A and B.
They like to interact.
It could be hydrogen bonding.
Could be a lot of
different things.
OK, so now if I put the
whole diagram together,
which I shouldn't
have erased here.
Right, so there's my
diagram here again.
There's Raoult's law.
There's the deviation
from Raoult's law here.
For one substance,
let's say for B. There's
Raoult's law for A. There's
a deviation for A. It
could be like this.
And if I now add
these two together,
instead of having
a diagram for, this
is a pressure xB, yB diagram,
pressure xB, yB diagram,
instead of having Raoult's
law sitting right here.
And then the yB part down
here below, your usual sort
of ideal solution phase
diagram with the high pressure
of the liquid on top and
the gas on the bottom.
Now if you add the blue curve
and the red curve together,
you're not going to
get a straight line
like you did before.
When Raoult's law
applied throughout.
Instead you're going
to get a deviation
from the straight line.
You're going to
get a curve that's
always below the straight line.
Because we have the negative
deviation on both sides.
So you end up with
something that's
curved and deviates below.
And the same thing will
happen for the bubble line.
It will also deviate below.
In some way.
Maybe not as much, maybe.
So this is what you usually see.
You see deviation of
that whole phase diagram,
like you're pushing down on it.
Or maybe it didn't pulled up.
If you have a
positive deviation,
then it's the opposite.
It gets, this is
negative deviation.
And if you have a
positive deviation,
instead of having a
usual phase diagram,
you're going to get something
that's looking like this.
Which is the Henry's
law coming in.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Doesn't matter.
Good question, though.
OK, so this is what
it usually looks like.
And everything
you've learned so far
can be applied to
these diagrams here.
There's one exception, though,
which is an important one.
Which is, sometimes,
these non-ideal diagrams
have a funny spot.
Which is that if I
draw them, so there's
my xB, yB, on the bottom.
Zero to one.
I have pressure here.
Sometimes, there's the dew line.
And the bubble line.
Sometimes, instead of
having a nice separation
between the bubble
and the dew line,
there's a special point
which for some reason
those two curves meet.
Non-ideality.
There's interaction
between the molecules.
In the gas phase and
the liquid phase.
This special point is
an interesting one.
Because, well, if I'm away
from this special point,
let's say I'm sitting to the
left of the special point,
right here.
And I can distill this thing.
I can take my gas phase here.
And increase the pressure.
Say I'm sitting here in
the mixture, gas phase
mixture with x prime B, y
prime B. Sorry, x prime B.
And I go up and I
increase the pressure.
Start making vapor.
Start making vapor, I
can find out what the,
I start making liquid.
I can find out where the
composition in the liquid
is by going over to
the blue line here.
That tells me the
composition in the liquid.
And reading off the composition
of the liquid down here.
So this is actually the
composition in the gas phase
is yB prime. yB prime
is the gas phase.
I'm starting here.
I start to increase
the pressure.
I begin the
distillation process.
And I get a little
bit of liquid out.
And I can read off the
composition in the liquid. xB
prime.
And I know from this diagram
that xB prime is less then
yB prime.
So I'm enriching
my liquid in A. I'm
purifying my
solution in A, right?
I can get pure A out eventually.
The fact of doing
this, I can get pure A.
So I decrease the pressure,
I get the pure gas phase
of my new solution here.
And I increase the pressure.
And go over and make a
little bit of liquid.
And capture that liquid.
And repeat the process
over and over again.
And eventually I have pure A.
Now, suppose I'm sitting
here at this special point.
And I'm starting with yB And
let me call it a here. yB of a.
I'm sitting right here.
And I'm increasing the pressure.
I go all the way up here.
And I start making liquid. .
What's the composition
of liquid, compared
to the composition
of the gas phase?
What's y?
What's xB compared to yB
of this point up here?
It's the same.
So I'm making liquid.
I got the same composition.
Doesn't help me.
If I make a gas again, I still
have the same composition.
I can't distill.
I can't purify it.
So if I have this special
mixture here, of A and B,
at this point here, I form
what's called an azeotrope.
And then you can't
separate it out.
You can't separate out
the mixtures into A and B.
You can't distill it
at that point here.
Now, you can draw the same
diagram in, instead of
pressure, mole fraction, you
can draw the same diagram
in terms of temperature.
And the same thing happens.
You can have
deviations from, this
is the extra figures that
are on the bottom page
of the notes from
last time here.
That we've replaced here.
You can have a
positive deviation.
With a positive azeotrope.
And your T p
diagram, T x diagram.
Or you can have, depending
on the interactions
between the two
molecules, you can
have something that has
a negative deviation.
And a negative azeotrope here.
So in this case here, this is
a particularly awful situation.
Because there's your
liquid phase down here.
There's the gas phase here.
And now, suppose
that you're doing
some sort of distillation.
So you start here in the liquid
phase, with some composition.
You make a gas.
Let's say you're doing a
fractional distillation
of some sort.
Your gas now has a new mixture.
So this is the composition
in the gas phase.
You take that gas phase
mixture, and you condense it
in your condenser.
In your fractional
distillation condenser.
So now I've condensed it.
And I heat it up again.
I've condensed it.
So I'm here somewhere.
And cool it down so
that I have a liquid.
And I condense it.
And slowly I move over
to the azeotrope point.
And once I get there, I'm stuck.
And the same thing happens
if I'm on the other side.
I'm on this point here, I
keep my solution, my mixture.
I make a gas, I read off the
composition of the gas phase
here.
I take my gas phase composition
out and I re-liquefy it.
So I'm here, down
here somewhere, again.
And I heat it up again.
And and I move to
the azeotrope point.
That's what happens if you have
a mixture of benzene and water,
for instance.
You can't distill it.
You work your way down
to this point here.
You can't use
fractional distillation
until you've separated it out.
So this is a real life problem.
And you have to do things
like change the pressure.
Do your distillation under
high pressure or low pressure.
To try to get this
point to separate out.
So you can get past this point.
Or to try to get the deviation
to become of the opposite sign.
Where you can start to
do some distillation.
Any questions on
azeotropes, before we
get to colligative properties?
If you're doing
organic chemistry,
and you're trying
to purify things,
this is a real pain, right?
Pain in the neck.
So you've got to know, which
things form azeotropes.
So we're going to start
colligative properties.
There are four
colligative properties,
and you already
know what they are.
And you've even seen
the math behind them.
And in fact, you've seen
the math for one of them
already pretty clearly.
And these colligative
properties are
properties that you use all the
time in your day to day life.
At least, three of them.
OK what are the four
colligative properties?
There is vapor
pressure lowering.
If you have a mixture and the
vapor pressure of the mixture
is less than the vapor
pressure of the pure material,
there's the boiling
point elevation.
If you add a large amount of
insoluble - not insoluble,
non-volatile solute to a
solution, you will depress,
you will increase the boiling
point of that solution like
the example of the salt
and water that I gave.
So if you need a lot
of salt to increase
the boiling point of water.
There's the freezing
point depression.
That's what we use to
melt ice in the winter.
By adding salt to it.
Then there's the
osmotic pressure.
Which is the example of the
freshwater fish in salt water,
or the saltwater
fish in fresh water.
Or the cells bursting
when you put them in.
OK, so these colligative
properties all come
from the fact if
I have a mixture,
the chemical potential of
a molecule in a mixture,
in the liquid
phase here, is less
than the chemical
potential of the pure guy.
Where A is the solvent,
and B is some solute.
So this is always true if
your number of moles of A
is much larger than
number of moles of B. Mix
a little bit of B in there,
and the chemical potential of A
in the liquid is
going to come down.
Because of the mixing process.
Because of the
entropy of mixing.
And that's going to give
rise to these properties.
And, to do these, one more
thing before we start.
We're going to use a special
concentration for these guys.
We're going to use,
call something molality.
Molality.
Molality is the number
of moles of solute
divided by kilograms of solvent.
So it's moles per
weight of solvent.
As opposed to moles
per liter, which
is something that
we're more used to.
Moles per kilograms of solvent.
It's pretty close to
moles for liter for water.
Because a gram of water
is a milliliter, roughly.
The density of
water's close to one.
So let's start on these things.
So we've already seen this.
You've already seen
vapor pressure lowering.
It comes from Raoult's law.
If I look at the change in
the vapor pressure of A, pA
minus pA star. pA is equal to
xA pA star. xA pA star, that's
Raoult's law.
Minus pA star, that's
equal to one minus xA.
Minus pA star.
Which is minus xB pA star.
Which is less than zero.
So, that means that the vapor
pressure above the solution
is lowered.
So I should have said
vapor pressure lowering.
And we also drew a
phase diagram to show
how this vapor
pressure lowering was
going to imply freezing point
depression and boiling point
depression.
So now let's go on and look at
the freezing point depression.
Number two.
We're going to find that the
change in the boiling point
is going to be some constant
K sub b, which is not
to be confused with
Henry's law's constant.
It's completely different.
This is a colligative property.
Times the molality
of B. That's going
to be the answer
we're going to get.
Amount of temperature
change depends linearly
on the molality of
B, with a constant
that depends on
what the mixture is.
And what the pressure is.
Whenever we derive anything
connected to phase transitions,
we usually always
start with the fact
that the chemical
potential changes.
And it has to be
equal at equilibrium.
So that's what
we're going to do.
We're going to start with
the chemical potential equal
of the liquid phase is equal
to the chemical potential
of the gas phase.
For the solvent at equilibrium.
And the liquid phase
obeys Raoult's law.
So it's going to be the chemical
potential of the pure material.
The pure liquid.
Plus RT log xA.
So this is where the mixing
of the solute comes in.
And on the gas phase
side, mu A, it's
going to be the same thing
as the chemical potential
of the pure A.
Because we're going
to take B to be non-volatile.
So the only thing
in the gas phase
is A. Same chemical
potential as if it were pure.
Because it is pure.
So now we solve for log xA
is equal to one over RT mu
A star in the gas phase minus
mu A star in the liquid phase.
And this is just the
Gibbs free energy
per mole of A in the gas phase.
The Gibbs free energy per
mole of A in the liquid phase.
So we can replace this with
the change in Gibbs free energy
from going from gas to liquid.
Per mole, which
is just the Gibbs
free energy of vaporization.
We're going from liquid to gas.
And I probably have a
negative sign somewhere.
No this is right, this
is the final state.
This is the initial state.
Divided by RT.
OK.
That's not really
what we want, though.
What we want is
delta T. Here I've
got some complicated
equation that has T in it,
but not delta T.
But before we do
that, before we transfer
and try to get a delta T out
of this equation,
let's see if we
can do any sort of
simplifications here.
I don't like to
carry logs around.
There are no logs around here.
So let's see if we can
get rid of that log.
What is log xA?
Log xA, well, xA
is close to one.
It's connected to xB.
And everything in
here is connected
to B. There's a
molality of B here.
The concentration of A
doesn't come into play here.
I don't want it there.
So let me replace it with B. one
minus xB. xB is a small number.
It's a solute, it's
in small amount.
We're close to being
a pure solvent here.
So one minus
something very small.
The log of that.
Well if you've worked
with Taylor's expansions.
You probably know that
that's close to minus xB.
The log of one minus
x where x goes to zero
is close to minus x.
So that's minus xB.
Now, minus xB, in
terms of the moles,
is the number of moles of B
divided by the number of moles
of B plus the number of moles
of A, the total number of moles.
The number of moles
of B is very small,
compared to the number of moles
of A. So I can get rid of this.
So, and there's a
minus sign here.
So this is approximately
minus nB divided by nA.
Now, the only I can do is, I'm
trying to get at molality here.
I said we're going
to use molality.
Got moles.
I don't have kilograms
of solvent here.
I have moles of solvent.
I'm not so happy with that.
So, in order to get something
that has kilograms out,
let's multiply up and down by
capital M where capital M is
that total mass of A. Basically
the number of kilograms
of solvent.
Total mass of A. So
now, this fraction here,
that's the molality.
That's what I'm looking for.
So this is minus the molality.
Then I have the total
mass of A divided
by the number of moles
of A. Well, that's
the molecular weight of it.
Total mass divided by
the number of moles
is the molecular weight.
So this is the molality of
B times the molecular weight
of A. OK.
So now I can plug this
instead of log xA.
And I get minus nB times
nA is equal to delta
G of vaporization divided by RT.
Let's rearrange a little bit.
And mB is equal to to delta
G vaporization divided
by nA times RT, with
a negative sign.
Well, I've eliminated
the log at least,
but I still don't have
a delta T in there.
I don't have a delta
T. How am I going
to get a delta T in there?
Got to get the delta T.
Everything's very small.
So one way to get a small
change in temperature
is to take a derivative
with respect to temperature.
That's going to get
a delta T in there.
So I'm going to take the
derivative of both sides
with respect to T.
And delta T is going
to come out that.
I'm going to take d nB
/ dT, constant pressure.
Minus one over mA times
R d delta G over T. This
is delta G of vaporization.
dT, constant pressure.
And I wish I'd made my
boards a little bit better.
Because I have to
cover things up.
OK, now I have this derivative
of the Gibbs free energy
divided by the temperature.
This turns out to be something
that you've seen before.
It's called the
Gibbs-Helmholtz equation.
And it relates the temperature
change in the Gibbs free energy
with the enthalpy change.
The Gibbs-Helmholtz equation
is that the d delta G over T dT
is equal to minus
delta H over T.
And you can get that from just
writing fundamental equations
about G and H. And
turning the crank.
And we've done that before.
And I'll leave that
as an exercise for you
to go back and figure
out what, you can go back
to your textbook and look
at, you know under the index.
Gibbs-Helmholtz, and figure
out why this is the case.
So now, we have
this equation here.
This is going to be
nice, because it's
going to get rid of the d/dT.
On the right-hand side.
And so now our
equation becomes d
mB / dT is equal to delta H
vaporization divided by mA R T
squared.
Now, I can rewrite this in
a slightly different way.
This is delta m over
delta T, basically.
Delta the change
in number of moles.
I mean, the molality
of B divided
by the change in temperature.
I'm getting very close here.
There's a change in
temperature here.
There's a change
in molality here.
I can rewrite this
as delta T, then,
is equal to molecular
weight of A times
RT squared divided by delta H
vaporization times delta mB.
Now, I'm making a very
small change in B here.
Starting at zero.
Basically I'm taking
pure A and I'm
dumping in a little
bit of B. That's
what I'm doing
when I experiment.
I'm dumping in a little
bit of B in my pure A,
and I'm trying to figure out
how the temperature is changing.
So I'm doing delta m sub
B is my small amount of B
that I'm adding to the solution.
Minus what I started out
with, which was zero.
So delta mB is basically
m sub B. Right?
That's basically what it is.
So let's get rid
of this delta here.
What else can I say?
Well, I can say that the
temperature change that I'm
looking at is also pretty small.
Compared to the
absolute temperature.
This is a small change.
I'm only adding a small
amount of B in there.
So this temperature up here is
not going to change very much.
Let's take it to
be the temperature
of the boiling point
of the pure material.
T sub B star, of
the pure material.
OK And there's my delta T here.
So this is of the
form delta T is
equal to molecular weight
of A. Times R. Times
the boiling point of the
pure material squared.
Divided by delta
H of vaporization
of the pure solvent.
Times the molality of B. And
this combination of properties
of A, the molecular weight of
A, the boiling point of pure A.
The heat of vaporization of
pure A, this is K sub b up here.
Which I covered up.
It's of the form delta T is
equal to K sub b times mB.
And this turns out to be
always greater than zero.
Now.
If you want to look at
freezing point depression,
it's really easy.
In your equations, it's the
same thermodynamic picture.
All you need to do,
in all your equations,
you replace delta
G of vaporization
with minus delta G of freezing.
When we did a vaporization,
we're going from liquid to gas.
We had delta G of vaporization.
When we're doing freezing
point depression,
we're going from
liquid to solid.
And so we have to use
minus delta G of fusion.
Minus delta H of
fusion. s to l would
be the positive
delta G of fusion.
So we're going from
liquid to solid.
We have to replace
delta G of vaporization
with delta G of fusion.
We replace delta
H of vaporization,
where minus delta H of fusion.
Replace the boiling point
with the freezing point.
And replace K sub
b with K sub f.
And the math is
exactly identical.
It all starts from the chemical
potentials being equal.
And turning the crank
at equilibrium, being
equal between the solid
phase and the liquid phase.
And turning the crank.
The solid phase is
like the gas phase.
It's a pure A, pretty much.
Because the molecules
of B are stuck.
And A doesn't know that B's
around, in the solid phase.
They know that they're
around in the liquid phase
because the fusion
fast enough. .
And then we can write,
if we turn the crank,
we get an equation
that looks like this.
The freezing point depression
is equal to minus mA
R Tf star squared.
Divided by delta H
of fusion, for mole.
Times the molality
of B. And this number
is always less than zero.
There's the negative
signs in here.
OK.
Always depressed.
Any questions about those
freezing point depression
and boiling point elevation.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] PROFESSOR:
Why did I drop it here?
Because the small change
that I'm making in nB
is going from pure
A, where nB is zero,
to a very small amount of nB.
That's why I'm
allowed to say this.
And then just replace
delta nB with nB.
I'm comparing every,
my reference point
is the pure material.
I'm just adding a little
bit to start with.
It's a good question.
Any other questions?
OK.
I didn't get to
osmotic pressure.
You'll get to that on Friday.
And also start
statistical mechanics.
And after osmotic pressure,
you'll be done with thermo.
It'll be statistical
mechanics and then kinetics.